have an absolutely adorable piece of
video to share with you this morning Las
Vegas Raiders wide receiver Devonte
Adams recently interviewed by one of his
biggest little fans take a look
so one of my greatest memories of my
life is going to your to your camp and
doing a seven on seven against yes sir
so what is one of your greatest memories
in your childhood
greatest memories in my childhood I
would say when I was young maybe about
seven or eight years old I had
opportunity to meet JJ Stokes who was on
the San Francisco 49ers at the time and
that memory stuck with me because I was
the first uh professional athlete that I
met that I met and it was just a great
experience really nice guy he helped out
all of all the young kids and gave us
great advice so I probably have to say
that
yeah
okay so Jeremiah only 10 years old the
cutest P he's got his own Instagram
account you've got to follow it sports
for free youth media he interviews lots
of local sports teams and players and uh
I had an opportunity to meet him at an
event where we were doing you know some
some food donations for folks in need
and that's when he told me look it's not
my birthday it's Jesus's birthday so
that's why I give back too he was
wearing a jacket he said because Miss
Sherry said it was going to be cold
Jeremiah you are a love bug he's a great
kid I've seen some of his videos he
credited me with a forecast when he was
doing play-by-play at a school sporting
event